so one of the cackling hens on the view
who seems to be
a member of this certain species of
upper-class white women
liberal upper-class white women she
articulated her extraordinarily neurotic
view
that life can never go back to normal
after covid
i think there's a prudence we've learned
with the mass the hand sanitate
hand sanitizing that kind of like 911
with flying is always going to be here
now there's a new normal in the
beginning when at post 911 people didn't
want to fly and the security measures
felt like uh how do we do this you know
and now it's the norm i think some of
the things we've learned in this
pandemic are going to stay the same i
may never write a subway again without a
mask i may never go indoors to big
crowds and never feel comfortable
without a mask and that's up to me to do
that
obviously this is insane behavior and an
insane way of viewing the world that you
will never see people again you will
never go into a large group of people
without covering up your face
so you'll never you'll never see a group
full of smiles again that's gone you
will never share air with a group of
people again you will never take public
transportation again without wearing a
secular hijab a kefia
that's insane behavior
but even beyond that she says look and
if you want to do that that's up to you
i don't think that should be up to you
how would you feel if you could get 25
cents back per gallon every time you go
to the pump you'd probably feel pretty
good about that what if i told you that
for your first fill up you could
actually get 50 cents per gallon cash
back you'd probably feel even better
about that what if i told you that you
could do all of this
for free with the free get upside app
that's right get the free get upside app
enter code knowles knoww les you will
save up to 50 cents per gallon
for your first fill up and then you'll
save 25 cents per gallon for every fill
up after that there's no catch just cash
back the cash gets added directly to
your bank account or it can go to paypal
if you prefer or it can go to an amazon
gift card or a gift card to some other
shop it is super easy people who drive a
lot are saving two to three hundred
bucks per year with get upside down load
the free get upside app use promo code
knowles to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank that is
code k-o-w-l-e-s
knowles
right now the debate on the masks is
over two positions
there's the leftist position which is
every single person needs to wear at
least one or two masks and then there's
the kind of conservative position which
is that if you want to wear a mask do it
and if you don't want to wear a mask
don't
that's kind of the squish position
i'd like to suggest a further position a
genuinely conservative position which is
you should not be permitted outside of
very rare exceptions very rare
circumstances you should not be
permitted to wear a mask in public
we do not want to be a society of
banditos that is disordered it's weird
we look like we're train robbers in the
wild west
it is not serving the medical function
that we were told it would after we were
told it would not after we were told it
would you know obviously it's gone back
and forth quite a lot because the public
health establishment is extremely
cynical and dishonest and deceptive
but we should not permit it i don't i do
not want to live in a society where
we're all covering up each other's faces
if you want to move to afghanistan if
you wanted that's fine go go i don't
care if the women on the view want to
move to afghanistan i'm not going to
stop them but i don't want to live in
that society and i have some rights to
decide
how this society is going to function
because i'm a citizen because i'm a
member of that society and i think there
are a whole lot of us who don't want to
live in this sterile world where we no
longer view our countrymen as our
brothers as our kinsfolk where we just
view them as walking bags of germs who
are going to kill us all i'm not i'm out
i don't want that okay and so in as much
as i have any political power i am going
to stop
i'm i'm on a mission of mercy i'm going
to stop these neurotic women on the view
from driving themselves even crazier
than they already are okay
take off the stupid masks
they're really dumb they're i'm not by
the way
by the way youtube by the way facebook
by the way big tech i'm not making any
medical claim here
i'm not making any claim about the
transmissibility and the how it affects
i'm not i'm making a political claim the
masks are dumb i hate them they're
disordered people should not use that
it's degrading take them off
okay that's my claim can't fact check me
on that it's obviously true
ring the bell
ring but then you'll get the
notifications maybe you won't get the
notifications then you got to go to
apple podcasts spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts
sign up the michael knowles show
leave a five star review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you